les difficultés du nouveau pouvoir
romain première réunion du front de
salut national première contestation
dans la rue
l'histoire en direct hier soir avec le
procès filmés de chaouch et ce coup ce
soir encore beaucoup de questions sans
réponse analyse l'aide afflue de tous
côtés et de france d'abord il s'agit
maintenant d'organiser correctement fait
l explication
le parti communiste français secoué par
la tragédie romaine ont testé de
l'intérieur critiqué de l'extérieur le
parti se défend
bonsoir au lendemain de l'incroyable
procès filmés de ceausescu la roumanie
tente de reprendre ses esprits
chacun commence maintenant à mesurer
l'ampleur véritable des problèmes tout
est à reconstruire dans ce pays
l'économie bien sûr mais aussi la vie
politique nous allons y revenir sans
compter que la situation sur le terrain
n'est toujours pas réglée même si le
calme revient
il y a encore des affrontements
sporadiques avec les hommes de la
securitate le front de salut national
leur a lancé un ultimatum ils doivent se
rendre avant demain 17 heures sinon ils
seront considérés comme des terroristes
la résistance de ces hommes et tonnes
après la chute de leur dictateur mais en
voyant les images qui vont suivre
on comprend mieux ce sont des images
d'une véritable ville parallèle d'une
ville souterraine bucarest ceausescu
avait créé pour assurer sa défense
personnelle
l'ampleur de ces souterrains vous allez
voir étonne encore même les roumains eux
mêmes
maryse mano on entre ici dans un autre
monde une ville secrète de tunnels
bétonné et sans fin tous les matins les
militaires découvrent de nouveaux
souterrain larmes au point la securitate
y est toujours embusqués
cet ascenseur descend jusqu'à la pièce
la plus secrète la chambre est le bon
coeur personnel de chez oc secours ici
les preuves de son départ précipité avec
les restes d'un repas abandonné dans ce
frigidaire plus de viande quand romain
moyen n'en consomme pendant l'année dans
ce labyrinthe équipée d'une
climatisation sophistiquée des centaines
d'agents de la securitate pouvait tenir
longtemps
certains ils sont en fort tel cet homme
fait les militaires viennent de
surprendre
on cherche d'abord l'éventuelle capsule
de cyanure caché dans la doublure de
savait rien cette fois ci mais une série
de papiers atteste qu'il appartient bien
à la securitate la possession d'orange
introuvable à bucarest est un indice
supplémentaire
personne ne connaît l'étendue de ce
réseau peut être des centaines de
kilomètres relie en bâtiments officiels
et points stratégiques de la capitale
la radio a lancé un appel aux
architectes pour qu'il fournisse les
plans de ces galeries le drame romain
telle une tragédie antique l'unité
d'action la chute d'un dictateur
unité de temps à peine une semaine hier
soir le monde entier avec via la
télévision le dernier acte de cette
tragédie
le procès du tyran déchu et même si l'on
n'en connaissait la fin puisque la
veille l'annoncé de son exécution avait
été faite même si on savait que chaouchi
secoue mourait à la fin de ce procès les
images dégager une étrange émotions vous
avez été très nombreux à suivre ce
procès retransmis en direct par antenne
2 hier soir vers 23 heures et vous
l'avez certainement senti il y avait la
dimension humaine de l'événement
l'arrogance mais aussi une certaine
dignité du dictateur enfin ce procès
expéditif de chauché secoué de sa femme
pose beaucoup de questions encore non
résolus hervé brusini récit et analyses
je ne dis mince et les spectateurs
28e et d'emblée tout est dit chers
téléspectateurs nous allons vous
présenter des aspects du procès des
inculpés ceausescu ce qui a été donné à
voir n'est donc un montage de
différentes scènes
mais d'abord qu'il voyons-nous les
chaouche et secoue bien sûr
et un militaire très obligeant un
médecin aussi au comportement clinique
et son assistant et le procès commence
vous êtes en face du tribunal du peuple
je ne reconnais aucune autorité si ce
n'est celle de la grande assemblée
nationale dit chercher secours mais
l'assemblée nationale a été dissoute
le nouveau système légal est différent
alors c'est un coup d'état l'ancien
hochet secours on vous juge selon la
nouvelle loi énoncées par le conseil du
front salut national et vous êtes priés
de vous mettre debout inculpé réponse
l'un constitution de l'état fait
autorité je cite la constitution et on
l'interrompt la constitution on la
connaît mieux que vous qu'il n'avait pas
respecté
je ne répondrai plus à aucune question
face à chaouchi secoue ses juges restent
invisibles et pourtant on pourrait
aisément les dénombrer regardez cet
homme porte le brassard du comité du
front de salut national
à gauche les mains d'un autre homme il
fume une cigarette et porte le costume
se serait donc peut-être un civil tous
ces gens sont debout
le montage ne respectent pas la
chronologie du procès au premier plan un
hommage et des cheveux blancs juste à
ses côtés celui là porte un pull-over
peut être un autre civil et à l'extrême
droite de l'écran un uniforme de l'armée
probablement l'un des deux avocats
tout au long du film ces images arrêtés
vont permettre d' occulter
l'identité des membres de la cour
laisser mourir les gens les enfants à
l'hôpital sans nourriture sans chauffage
sans lumière ça ne vous a pas surpris
tout ça je parle à l'inculpé nicolas
ceausescu
au nom de quoi était perpétré le
génocide de timisoara
à toutes ces questions aucune réponse
et voilà pourquoi le peuple lutte pour
le pays
ceausescu car il veut éliminer cette
bande de traîtres
avec l'aide de l'étranger qui ont
organisé un coup d'état
et peu à peu nicolas ceausescu va
retrouver le ton les expressions les
gestes du dictateur qu'il fut à
plusieurs reprises et que la chercher ce
coup tentera d'empêcher sa femme de
répondre aux questions des juges le
procureur a lui reproché d'avoir vécu
essentiellement avec des étrangers lui
l'ardent nationaliste et chercher ce
coup s'esclaffe
l'avocat demande que l'on supprime la
peine de mort pour son client
un client qui regarde sa montre
impatience devant une parodie de procès
ou espoir car il sait qu'au dehors les
hommes de la securitate et se battent
encore pour lui je vous rappelle dit il
que lorsque j'allais dans les usines en
face des travailleurs ne continue en
plus dit l'avocat qui se fait procureur
c'est une décision de la justice
populaire roumaine brut chaises tout le
monde se lève on va délibérer c'est
épaulettes c'est un militaire autour de
la cour
la sentence est définitif dit l'avoir
ceausescu a peut être alors compris que
la mort était vraiment proche
alors comment ça se passe et comment
comment que j'exploite il réagi après
procès
url
il a pleuré ce qu'il a dit ce soir à la
télévision comme vous l'avez dumouriez
discours oui il était criblé de se
retenir de il a essayé de courir et
c'était que c'était dur pour lui de
terminer je ne paye pas tous passer
complètement honnête on a même filmé
tout ça c'est parce que le sujet d'une
action de vengeance et de vous êtes un
militaire c'était donc lui l homme aux
cheveux blancs présents lors du procès
il devait en être l'un des procureurs
on l'avait vu à plusieurs reprises à la
télévision quelques jours auparavant
comme chaque soir nous sommes en direct
avec nos envoyés spéciaux à bucarest
nous retrouvons ce soir françoise joly
bonsoir françoise alors est-ce que ce
procès qui a été j'imagine très suivi
bien sûr par les romains est-ce qu'il
est encore très commentée à bucarest ce
soir bonsoir des biens tout d'abord je
voudrais vous dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
monde autour de mou notamment toutes ces
personnes qui sont les agents de
sécurité de l'ambassade de france ici à
bucarest et qui nous ont protégés tous
ces derniers jours alors comment a réagi
la population au procès de nicolae
ceaucescu et bien comme l annonce de son
exécution par la frustration
il n'y aura pas de procès public par un
tribunal ce qui aurait permis peut-être
certaines révélations sur le rôle de
tous ceux qui ont entouré nicolae
ceausescu pendant ces 24 ans de tyrannie
pour le peuple rouge
vous savez l'effervescence ici à
bucarest aujourd'hui est bien à l'été au
ministère des affaires étrangères car
c'était là qu'était réunit des
intellectuels des dissidents et des
hauts responsables de l'armée
ils formaient un conseil avec le premier
ministre et ce conseil devrait
constituer le gouvernement dans son
ensemble
tout cela se passait dans une ambiance
très des contacts très décontracté voici
le reportage de patricia lacoste
fonderie c est jean michel noël nous
allons voir votre reportage prend soif
qui n'est pas parti mais nous allons
devoir tout de suite le reportage de
patricia lacoste sur le nouveau
gouvernement la salle du conseil le
faire des grands jours hier au ministère
des affaires étrangères une multitude de
journalistes cherchent à obtenir
quelques mots de toutes les grandes
figures des dissidents hier dans des
cachots aujourd'hui promu membre du
nouveau conseil de salut public des
élections libres
son père ici corneille ou manescu l'un
des six grands dignitaires avoir signé
dernièrement une lettre contre ceausescu
la zunie trou mais tous nous un ancien
défenseur des droits de l'homme et
l'euphorie nous allons dit-il promouvoir
maintenant le meilleur sur cette terre
nous allons sortir le pays de la misère
et le réintégrer à l'europe d'en payer
les achats mais mollo instant historique
voici le conseil de salut public romain
dans sa formule élargi regroupant toutes
les composantes de l'opposition de ses
militaires le président au centre et
trouve le vice-président bâtiment et le
jeune premier ministre promet et puis
semblable à elle même la plus illustre
des dissidents trop même doina tornay
attention de jouer un rôle vous avez la
politique
non non tant que je suis encore le deal
est nécessaire je ne veux pas abandonner
oui mais après non non
vous êtes réunis pour la première fois
ici autour de ce conseil et quelle
impression vous avez registre c'est
parce que j'aimerais que nous restions
suis ici et c'est un mauvais indice que
vous a invité de quitter la surprend
après le travail
après le service elle m'a appelé
l'api je crois piri weepu nous il mais
encore une fois ça n'a pas de sens je
crois que
vous voudriez qu'on participe avec vous
au travail sur le pays tout en offrant
un n
au fond et c'est toute l'europe qui nous
a aidés qui nous a protégés tout est
simple une solidarité européenne je
crois que les choses n'auraient pas
cessé pour cible du fis en roumanie
françoise on a vu donc l'installation du
nouveau conseil de ce nouveau front
alors c'est vrai aussi on a vu dès hier
soir qu'il était déjà ce nouveau pouvoir
contesté dans la rue
oui avait ce pouvoir est contesté mais
principalement par les étudiants vous
savez que ce sont eux qui ont payé de
leur vie de leur sens le renversement de
la dictature de ceausescu
alors aujourd'hui je suis allé les voir
dans leur université regardez ce
reportage que j'ai réalisé avec roger
motte énorme versailles et il fait
sombre dans cette salle de l'université
de bucarest le les lumières sont
maintenant allumée toute la journée
ceausescu lui a usé épuisé les yeux les
regards de ses étudiants en leur
autorisant peu quatre heures
d'électricité par jour
par mesure d'économie disait-il
dragos panne 23 ans quatrième année
d'électronique participé aujourd'hui aux
premières élections libres à
l'université depuis le début de la
révolution il a vu mourir plusieurs de
ses camarades
alors il ne veut pas que le nouveau
gouvernement s'approprie une liberté si
chèrement accueillis était la première
où ont pris le pouvoir dans la
radiotélévision à romain ils ne sont pas
élus il est mou se feront encore plus
dur pour parler du premier ministre être
romane
car cet étudiant a beaucoup entendu
parler de cet homme nous avons des
grands succès
parce que voilà le premier ministre
aurait soeur d'un autre institut
polytechnique
on les connaît suffisamment bien il a
été un grand activiste du parti
communiste
son père est arrivé ce parti communiste
ce premier ministre d'être trop mal et
un parvenu il est parvenu de parti
communiste je veux dire que il est un
homme avide de pouvoir
nos soupçons ne soupçonnant qu ils ne
représentent pas à l'affût de toute
information et surtout parce que depuis
le début les événements le centre du
pouvoir c'est la radiotélévision les
étudiants regarde en permanence
les cramps théâtre mais cette vision là
encore trop institutionnel il la
conteste déjà on ne te voit à la
télévision
les nouvelles les nouvelles que nous
avons besoin maintenant c'est à dire
quelle nouvelle pardon telle nouvelle
les nouvelles de qu'est ce qui se passe
dans le but d'en vu qu'avec qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec les terroristes dans
quel état nous sommes maintenant dans
quel état et l'armée on ne dit rien de
cela ils devaient tous ces doutes
toutes ces inquiétudes les jeunes
garçons prêts à donner du temps à ce
gouvernement qui veulent provisoire le
temps que rené sion vie politique une
vie démocratique
en roumanie qui ont françoise ce soir
est ce que le calme est vraiment revenu
dans tout bucarest t avais je ne dirais
pas que la situation est redevenue
normale ici à bucarest
parce que les chars stationnent toujours
au coin des rues mais vraiment nous
vivons peut-être pour la première fois
un retour au calme voilà hervé bonsoir
et jeu et je vous donne rendez vous dans
nos prochaines éditions
merci françoise merci à tous nos envoyés
spéciaux et puis après les problèmes
politiques il y a aussi les problèmes
économiques reconstruire l'industrie est
tout simplement réorganiser la vie de
chaque jour approvisionner la nourriture
par exemple c'est tout simple voyons
comment tout cela se passe dans les rues
de bucarest avec corinne virtuelle d
orange on n'en avait pas vu depuis
longtemps dans les magasins de bucarest
elle était réservée jusqu'ici à la
nomenclature a depuis aujourd'hui enfin
les roumains peuvent se ravitailler
le nouveau gouvernement l'a décidé pour
bien marquer la rupture avec la
dictature
les exportations vers l'étranger sont
arrêtés les denrées alimentaires sont
désormais en priorité pour le peuple
roumain
du coup on trouve de tout des oeufs de
la viande
cette viande roumaine qui partait
auparavant pour l'urss
mais même si la vie revient peu à peu à
la normale
l' équilibre de la situation reste
fragile les attaques isolées des agents
de la sécurité
sont toujours à craindre c'est pour cela
que le conseil de salut national a lancé
un ultimatum à tous ceux qui détiennent
des armes
ils doivent déposer revolver mais aussi
explosif et même talkie walkie avant
demain 17 heures sous peine d'être
considéré comme terroriste
ils seraient alors jugées par des
tribunaux militaires et condamné à mort
mais ce que les roumains retiendront
aussi de la journée d'aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il a neigé et que la température
était de 20 degrés dans les appartements
c'était la première fois depuis 25 ans
d'habitude le chauffage central marchait
en alternance avec l'eau chaude
un jour sur deux c'est cela aussi la
révolution voilà et tout de suite
une information dont je prends
connaissance en lisant le cran de mon
ordinateur une réaction de monsieur
perez de cuellar le secrétaire général
de l'onu monsieur des coûts et l'armée
beaucoup d'espoir dans la restauration
de la démocratie en roumanie
ce sont ses propres termes ainsi donc
tout de même les problèmes politiques
s'accumulent les problèmes économiques
aussi jacques merino ce ne sera pas
facile pour nouveau pouvoir
oui c'est vrai que la situation
politique est fragile elle peut être
même devenir dangereuse premier constat
l'absence de tradition démocratique en
roumanie ce pays vit depuis 1936 sous
des dictatures d'abba d'extrême droite
quentin escoumes 140 fut l'allié du
caire puis stalinienne à partir de 1946
ce qui fait que tout room ayant moins de
54 ans n'a jamais connu la démocratie
second constat le nouveau pouvoir qui se
met en place n'a pas encore exprimé sa
véritable volonté de rompre
définitivement avec le communisme ses
principaux dirigeants ce sont des
comices gorbatchev bien or de plus en
plus de manifestations
on l'a encore vu ce soir s'organise sur
le thème le communisme même à visage
humain on n'en veut plus sous-entendu la
passe rica ce n'est pas assez on veut la
liberté et toute la liberté
troisième constat de nouveaux partis
politiques fleuriste en roumanie deux se
sont créé hier un parti national paysan
est un parti démocrate-chrétien ces
partis sont déjà en conflit avec le
nouveau gouvernement qui leur
interdirait l'accès à la télévision
puis alors le dernier point jacques
merlino ses larmes et ça c'est une
grande question qu'est ce qu'elle va
faire
et oui cette armée est la cub déjà un
rôle essentiel dans les nouvelles
instances elle a joué un rôle important
dans la chute de ceausescu est ce
qu'elle est prête à rentrer dans ses
casernes lorsque le calme sera
complètement revenue et a laissé la
place à un gouvernement démocratique
c'est une question grave à laquelle
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas encore de
réponse certaine
merci jacques ce soir à paris une messe
à notre-dame pour les victimes roumaine
de cette révolution
une procession défilé aussi il ya
quelques minutes entre l'église romaine
de paris qui se trouve rue jean de
beauvais dans le 5ème arrondissement et
à notre dame où donc avait lieu une
messe recueillement bien sûr
recueillement de tous et romain et de
tous ses sympathisants
enfin l'aide à la roumanie tous les
jours de nouvelles bonnes volontés se
manifestent pour aider le peuple roumain
mais ce n'est pas toujours de la bonne
manière
comment acheminer cette aide par train
ou par camion que faut-il donner
quel effort faut-il faire en priorité
c'est toute une organiser une
organisation pardon qui peu à peu se met
en place
véronique ya l'yonne
à l'autre bout du fil un enfant propose
20 francs pour la roumanie
un supermarché offre 100 tonnes de
nourriture des chômeurs et des
militaires en retraite ont même appelé
pour partir là-bas 24 heures sur 24 une
dizaine de bénévoles oriente vers les
daces mairie ou associations locales le
standard de la cellule d'urgence est
saturé c'est une répondeur a explosé
contre dallas est nouveau c'est la
première fois que ça arrivait mais il ya
eu je crois autour de 5000 appels entre
1h et 5h du matin c'est absolument fou
et on avait décidé bêtement je crois de
fermer le numéro vert pendant quatre
heures pour aller un peu dormi et on
sent démandé les doigts ce matin argent
vêtements médicaments
les dons affluent de toutes parts de
petites communes parraine des villages
roumains se mobilisent pour donner tous
azimuts plus de 100 tonnes de chocolats
de noël attend encore dans les dépôts
mais en roumanie
on attend autre chose je pense qu'il
faut substituer l'argent aux dons en
nature
vous savez nous avons 20 ans
d'expérience et des catastrophes
naturelles et des catastrophes
politiques et de toutes sortes de
bouleversements un moment donné pour
adapter l'offre à la demande
il faut être souple il faut pas être
dépassé par cet amas terrible dont la
gérance est plus lourde encore que le
bénéfice l'essentiel des dons et
transféré sur paris le troisième train
de 800 tonnes vient d'être rempli des
trains qui remplace à présent les avions
de premières aides médicales et les
camions souvent restés bloqués à
l'entrée du pays
à présent c'est là bas qu'il faut
s'organiser pour réceptionner tous ces
convois de la solidarité
étrange maladie du milieu politique
français
le syndrome romain dans chaque partie on
tente de se justifier sur les relations
que l'un ou l'autre a eues avec l'ancien
dictateur ceausescu le plus attaqués
c'est bien sûr le parti communiste qui a
longtemps eu une attitude bienveillante
envers l'ancien régime room attitude
dénoncée même à l'intérieur du parti
communiste par certains contestataires
la direction du pc s'offusque et contre
attaque henry et les volets clos chez
georges marchais invisible depuis son
passage à l'hôpital
wazières il ya deux semaines et
quasiment muet au sujet des événements
en roumanie il se reposeraient seul
andré lajoinie dans sa résidence du
libérant sur les conseils de son médecin
dommage tout de même qu'il ne puisse
répondre aux attaques dans son parti est
l'objet depuis quelques jours certains
communistes toujours membre du pc les
reconstructeurs n'hésitent plus en effet
à demander purement la démission non
seulement de georges marchais mais du
bureau politique tout entier
n'apprécions pas la formule du globe du
bilan globalement positif et les faits
et la santé moigne nous pensons qu'il
faut faire un bilan réel de ce qu'est le
socialisme dans les pays socialistes
avoir une réflexion sur le
fonctionnement des partis communistes y
compris en france nous l'avons demandé à
maintes reprises
cela nous a été refusé il arrive un
moment où il faut prendre ses
responsabilités polémique communaux
communiste puisque ce matin l'on peut
lire dans l'humanité sous la plume de
claude cabanes que finalement et je cite
il serait peut-être plus prudent pour
certains spécialistes de la harangue de
baisser d'un ton en réalité cette
campagne vise à affaiblir le parti
communiste parce que le parti gomis mène
la lutte contre la politique d'austérité
du pouvoir l'ennui c'est que les
dirigeants de la place du colonel fabien
semblent eux aussi avoir la mémoire qui
flanche puisqu'en juillet 78 georges
marchais lui même était allé comme de
coutume passer ses vacances au bord de
la mer noire et ce à l'invitation
personnelle du génie des carpates
enfin pierre bleue d'un membre du bureau
politique représentait bel et bien le pc
français lors du dernier congrès du pc
roumains en novembre dernier juste avant
que n'éclatent les événements de
bucarest
et même s'il n'a pas cautionner le
régime par ses applaudissements
sa présence seule laisse vraiment un
goût très amer il ya tout de même des
pays où la transition entre le
communisme et le nouveau pouvoir
s'effectuer en douceur c'est le cas de
la tchécoslovaquie qui va élire après
demain son nouveau président un seul
candidat va cela babel l'écrivain
comment se prépare l'arrivée d'un poète
à la tête d'une démocratie populaire
christophe martet andré saura ont suivi
sa campagne électorale à prague
cette salle d'exposition est devenu le
centre nerveux de la campagne de vannes
laval elle ici on vient de toute la
tchécoslovaquie pour collecter des
tracts des affiches des informations je
viens de la campagne est là bas
l'information ne circule pas très bien
je suis venu chercher du matériel pour
l'emporter en moravie à 300 kilomètres
d'ici
depuis quinze jours qu'une armée de
bénévoles surtout des étudiants se
relaient pour préparer le matériel
l'ambiance est plutôt bon enfant
pour beaucoup c'est la première
expérience de la démocratie
bien sûr ce n'est pas un travail très
enrichissant mais au moins j'ai le
sentiment d'être utile de participer à
quelque chose d'important
retrouver des centaines de milliers de
photos de vaclav havel ont été tirées et
recouvre maintenant les murs de la ville
dans les rues on se les arrache
et même si le parlement à majorité
communiste qui procédera à l'élection
tous ici sont persuadés que l'ancien
dissident sera bien le prochain
président de la république
tchécoslovaque un tramway même été
réquisitionnés pour exprimer ce désir
panama noriega ne sera pas extradé vers
les états unis
c'est ce qu'a réaffirmé le porte parole
du vatican vous savez que l'ancien
dictateur réfugié dans l'ambassade du
vatican à panama explications louis
carzou qui détaille aussi les autres
informations de ce jeudi le général
noriega toujours réfugié à la nonciature
apostolique de panama mais une solution
pourrait être trouvée dans les prochains
jours selon le vatican de leur côté les
etats-unis ont réaffirmé aujourd'hui
leur souhait de voir le dictateur déchu
transféré aux usa
cependant le nouveau président panaméen
guillermo endara souhaite lui que le
jugement du général noriega et lieu au
panama
georgina dufoix sous protection
policière après l'attentât perpétré
samedi dernier contre sa voiture un
inconnu qui s'était introduit dans la
propriété de nîmes a tiré à plusieurs
reprises sur la voiture de la présidente
de la croix rouge française ainsi que
sur celles de son mari madame du foie
qui est également délégué général à la
lutte contre la drogue avait fait
l'objet de menaces téléphoniques
jean-charles willoquet ex ennemi numéro
un libéré aujourd'hui après 14 ans de
réclusion criminelle jean charles
willoquet avait été condamné en 77 à 20
ans de réclusion pour deux tentatives de
meurtre et une prise d'otages commise
lors de son évasion du palais de justice
de paris
français devrait entendre dans les
prochaines heures ludovic audhuy le fils
de la famille massacrée le 20 décembre
dernier dans une ferme de gironde
le jeune homme de 27 ans considéré comme
le témoin numéro un du drame s'est
présenté dans la matinée au consulat de
france à madrid
il affirme avoir assisté au meurtre de
ses parents
léger regain aujourd'hui à la bourse de
paris où la séance s'est achevée sur une
hausse de 0 41%
mais la devise américaine continue elle
de faire grise mine le dollar peut être
aujourd'hui 579 les chiffres et quelques
rendez-vous maintenant les chiffres ce
sont ceux du tiercé tout au moins les
pronostics que nous propose pierrette
brès les voici sur votre écran tiercé
quarté fin demain à vincennes le 16 le
15 le dise le 17 le 9 le 14 le 18 et le
4 les rendez vous c'est d'abord la météo
avec sophie davant et puis n'oubliez pas
22h25 l'émission place publique spéciale
bucarest consacré aux événements de
roumanie toute l'équipe de place
publique animée par claude sérillon va
vous faire revivre ces sept jours qui
ont marqué l'histoire c'est sept jours
en roumanie
et sachez que cette émission
exceptionnelle sera retransmise tout à
l'heure par la télévision roumaine elle
même le dernier journal ce sera aussitôt
après vers 23h25 23h30 ce sera philippe
gassot qui le présentera demain matin
les premiers journaux de la rédaction
seront présentés par isabelle bechler et
claire chazal à partir de 7 heures bonne
soirée sur antenne 2 à demain 20 heures